often times leaders see themselves as
the role of the hero or is the
protagonist of the story and sees the
people that follow them as bit players
and leaders play the executive program
in leadership is any program designed to
give people a set of skills and
knowledge to increase their leadership
ability to go from being an emergent
leaders moving more into a role in which
they are leading big teams whole units
are perhaps whole organizations what
we're trying to do in ppl is some people
understand that everyone's the hero on
their own story and the more you
understand it the more you can
internalize that belief I think the
better leader you can be I wanted to get
a broader perspective on leadership
throughout my life I've been leading by
instinct I felt it is about time I add
to my leadership skills in a structured
formal environment I wanted to attend
for my own personal development the
betterment of our company and for the
Stanford brand one thing that's unique
about Stanford is that focus on
experiential learning creating
activities allow you to experience the
concepts that we're talking about that
more deeply embeds the ideas into you so
that you can embody them when you get
back to the job one of the things that
the program has taught me is that by
better understanding my own leadership
style I am going to be more aware of how
other people experience me and how I can
help them to become better leaders the
program was very good at how to set
concrete steps towards achieving the
goals that you set for yourself
the ability to lead changes a big part
of the EPL program how do you engineer
change in the organization change in the
culture what constitutes a culture
making decisions about what kind of
culture is most useful for your
organization to be an effective leader
you need to both be able to understand
yourself in a deep way understand how
other people experience themselves and
in all those things together will allow
you to create a story to craft the
persona
it allows you to lead the team or the
organization more effectively there is
so much that we are all taking away from
this experience for anybody who hasn't
been here you need to be at Stanford for
this program I'm going to go home a
better person stronger more vibrant and
dynamic than ever I'm gonna go home to
make sure I bring a change that web
transform my organization
you